[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsey show where
we talk about your life your money your
work and your relationships i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague rachel
cruz we are ramsey personalities and
we're here together for you this hour
the phone number to jump in is triple
eight eight two five
5225 triple eight eight two excuse me
eight two five five two two five now
rachel will focus obviously on the money
questions i will chime in if if possible
and i'm here to help a little bit about
your work today because your work and
your money are absolutely connected and
we want to help you win in both areas so
if you need a bigger shovel to be able
to pay debt off faster get through those
baby steps faster i want to help you
with that if you're in a toxic work
environment that affects your income so
we'll help you with your work and money
specifically today but it's always fun
to be with you so yes exciting to see
you i know we haven't co-hosted together
quite a while it's great is it my
cologne is it is it a little off-putting
just like don't put me with ken
whenever i host don't put me with you
it's too much it sears the irises it's
it's too much well we're excited to be
together we're going to start off north
of the border ontario canada is where
william joins us william how can we help
hey guys i'm good how are you we are
having a blast what's going on with you
today
well i
have a question that sort of wraps a few
things into one but essentially i'm
wondering if i should sell the shares i
have in a company i co-loan
in order to pay off our mortgage and
have more time for another small
business that
we kind of have going on the side and
want to grow
wow tell me about the business
also the current one that i'm partnering
two separate businesses um it's a
internet rural internet business that we
run so we sell internet to people out in
the country
so
yeah something we started two years ago
right before covid so it kind of
exploded when everyone moved to work and
at home yeah
so it ended up working quite well and
what we want to move towards is a small
farm business that we've kind of been
doing on the side already
and i'd like to have more time to do
that sure what is your income right now
your main source of income is it this uh
internet company
uh
so that would probably only be about 10
of our income and then the other
business i own is a security home
security and business security business
okay um so that's probably about
80 to 90 percent okay
so if you sell the shares of this
internet company uh will you still draw
income or does that mean you're
completely out as an owner
i would be completely out what would
your uh would you what would you make on
the sale of the of the shares
about 350. how much do you owe in your
house
320. wow
put you in good position william so if
i'm hearing everything right you cash
out of this business that you don't want
to be in long term
and you're only drawing about 10 percent
of your income from that anyway and
you've got a side business in addition
to the security business you got a farm
business that's your long-term goal so
if i'm hearing everything correct this
makes you completely debt free and you
get out of a business that you don't
want to be in anyway is that what i'm
hearing
yeah that's right and rachel i guess
well yeah my question is what's the
hesitation like what what because to me
i'm like i kind of kind of feels like a
simple answer uh just being the third
party listening in
so what caused you to call and ask like
what's your hesitation
well i'm only 26 and this is kind of the
third business i've been part of already
since working with
the boss i started with
so
i'm just
my wife and i are both kind of worried
that this will be a pattern moving
forward that
i just
start something kind of lose interest
and just keep doing a cycle like that
okay so
just trying to figure out i guess if
this is just something i'm going to keep
doing or
financially it seems to make sense right
now but i
yeah yeah is the business growing are
you guys making more and more and how
much time do you spend in that business
the internet business
uh the internet one it's not growing too
much right now okay um
i spent a lot of time in it
no oh no okay okay
i was gonna say you know if you're not
spending a ton of time and it's like
skyrocketing would you hold and wait and
then buy out in two years you know what
i mean when you're making more that
could be the other side of the argument
but i think where you're at today i
think kind of and i think to simplifying
your life william you have three things
going on
so part of me would almost just not even
want the hassle of it and your said like
it's not even growing that much so it's
not like you're gonna miss out on a ton
of roi in the next few years like
getting out now
feels like the right move to me yeah so
there's two things i hear what you're
saying i i think you and your does your
wife have the concern or is is it your
concern that you're this well i'm this
serial entrepreneur and i'm starting and
i'm quitting and i'm starting is that
mostly coming from you and she kind of
sees it or is this a joint belief that's
what i'm curious about
i think we both
see that equally on my side it's just
i'm worried that i'll never be happy
with one
one thing necessarily and for her it's
more of the stability no question
no question okay great so a couple
things
number one uh i want to know how long
would it take you to pay off a house if
you did not cash the stock in so let's
say you guys were to keep paying it
going after as hard as you could but
just from traditional income not selling
the stock in this company how long would
it take you to pay off the house
i'm thinking seven to ten years like
we're we're probably a little tight
right now with
um with the mortgage from the house that
we have all right so i would i agree
with rachel i'd go ahead and do this
this is a solid move you're 26 and
you'll have no debt
and you no longer are we tight with the
mortgage um but let me address the
concern
first of all i understand where your
wife is at so i've been married 24 years
you're gonna have to always be
addressing that stability issue and her
safety
but you've been very very successful and
what i'm most curious about is how much
the two of you are excited about this
farm business
is she equally excited about that
how big of a passion dream is that
yeah she's very excited about it and
sees herself working in that as well
doing different things and we already do
a little bit of it and we have the hobby
farm
already so here's the deal yeah if i'm
sitting with the two of you at your
dinner table tonight
uh just kind of big brother in it i'm
telling you to cash out
because this is going to fast forward
the dream
of working on the farm having lots of
options you want to talk about stability
and i would just speak to this that hey
babe this is an equal dream for me too
and this is gonna when we're when we're
no debt at all
uh we're gonna be self-sustainable not
just by financially but you know even
the ability to just live off the grid if
you will so i think stability is the
message here i think this is the move
for stability rachel yeah and to speak
to the discontentment part william
there's a part of me that kind of just
wants to release you from that to say
like i think that there's now i'll say
this there's uh having enough
self-awareness that if you know that
about yourself that's good so i think
having the the awareness is huge but i'd
also say there's two camps of people
number one there's a camp of people in
their 20s who are still figuring out
what you want to do with your lives the
fact that you kind of moved around that
doesn't bother me a ton again with the
self-awareness of oh is this
discontentment but figuring out what you
want to do and then the camp of people
because i we have a friend like this and
he's just great with ideas
starting something and he'll start
something and he moves the next one it's
like what he does as a job and it's not
not necessarily a bad thing so
discontentment i think great
self-awareness but also don't be down on
yourself because of the moves you've
made so far i think it can be very
normal
yeah william i think rachel made a
wonderful point you're a starter by
nature and you need to lean into that
that's not a negative thing just don't
start something that you don't care
about that would be the only filter for
you appreciate the call
sell it
pay off the house that's exciting and
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free
shipping with blinds.com there's no need
to renovate your entire home just change
out what's on your windows with upscale
choices like faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back america you have joined the
conversation here on the ramsey show i'm
ken coleman she is rachel cruz and we're
here for you aaa 825
5225 that's the numbers toll free triple
eight eight two five
825-5225 let's go to the big apple new
york city new york brian joins us there
brian how can we help
yes how you doing thank you for taking
my call sure um
yeah
should i take a consolidated loan or a
personal loan to pay off credit card
debt
in efforts to improve my credit score
and build credit history
i'll give you a short answer no
and i'll tell you why brian you know
when people go to shift their debt
around um there's one time that we
actually say that it's not necessarily a
terrible idea and it's if you have
you know a larger debt but you're able
to get a loan that's less interest rate
and you're you're in the works to pay it
off um
then sometimes we're like you know what
it makes sense and you can do that
because your behavior was already that
i'm going to be paying this debt off
but just hearing your question and the
motivation why to do that i would say no
um because our goal
with our fun with our money at least
what we teach on this show is to be
completely debt free and not to be at
the mercy even of a credit score and so
we even teach to the point that you
become debt free and within around 12 to
18 months
after you become completely debt free
that credit score starts to actually go
down to undetermined and you end up not
really even having a credit score so
that's something that we talk about on
the show so in to in order to improve a
credit score is no is not a reason we
would do a financial move or what i
would suggest that you do so what kind
of debt is it in general is it all is it
all credit cards
yeah it's all credit card it's it's only
around 7 500. um i don't have a lot of
credit history so i thought paying back
a loan would help show some type of
credit history
yeah and it and it would but again my my
goal for you then
my goal for you is to still just pay
this off and not to work your your money
and your financial plan around the
credit score because
you can still today live life without a
credit score you can even get a mortgage
without a credit score through manual
underwriting so i don't want the credit
score to be the motivation of why you do
things because it's basically an isle of
debt score every way that your credit
score is calculated is an interaction
with debt whether it's the type of debt
you have the new types of debt you bring
on how often you pay your debt i mean
it's all calculated around debt
and
again having no debt and being
completely debt free
gives you so many other options in life
and such freedom which is which is what
we is what we talk about on the show
yeah what's your plan to pay off the 7
500 if you were not to get a loan
you had a timeline
um
i do probably in the next 12 months i
have the money to pay it off i'm paying
it off little by little my i just my my
long-term thing is i'm stuck at a credit
score at like 660 for a long time
and
i want to i want to raise that
i guess i'm focused on that credit score
but also i wanted i want to show that i
could pay a loan off because i do want
to get a mortgage in the next you know
24 to 36 months
so i'm just wondering how well you don't
need as rachel's address this you don't
need a credit score to get a loan for a
house
that's a that's a cultural myth
number one number two
and again rachel's made this very clear
and i agree with 100 but you realize
your credit score will go up when you
pay off the credit cards
momentarily
you know because it showed that you paid
them off well it jumped for a for a
short amount of time it shows that you
paid off their credit cards how much
money do you have in savings right now
you guys are gonna let uh get mad i have
enough money to pay off my the the debt
um i have around nine or 9 500 in
savings um
so i know it doesn't make sense probably
i know i should just probably pay that
off but it's like that cushion to know
that i have money in savings i guess
that's what i'm holding how much money
do you make what's your salary what's
your net take home
uh 85 000. okay
rachel i mean he can replenish that so
he can replenish that yeah but you can
pay
what other debt do you have brian
just have a car lease and um
child support that's my main two monthly
payments yeah
well i if i were in your position i
probably wouldn't be buying a home in
the next 24 months um i think it's going
to be a little bit longer for you just
from again doing it in a way that all of
this is a blessing and not a curse and
our goal was for you
to be financially free to be able to
build wealth and the fastest way to do
that from point a to point b what we
found is being completely debt free so
yeah paying this off replenishing that
emergency fund because i get it and and
and we hear you that like it's like oh
my gosh i'm only gonna have two thousand
dollars we even teach it just have a
thousand dollar emergency fund and pay
all your debt off and that urgency there
will also be the motivation for you to
build up that emergency fund that much
faster so building up a three to six
months worth of expenses and then a good
down payment so again it may take i mean
you could you may be able to do that in
in two years depending on all your
living expenses being in new york you're
in an expensive place
um
but yeah being able to get out of this
car release all of that just being
completely free from payments and i and
brian i just we've just we've studied
this for over three decades and have
been focused on people building wealth
lasting wealth
and the whole idea of the credit score i
just got to tell you it is just part of
this toxic
money industry where they keep you in
this in the system
and again you're you have to continue to
accumulate new debts to continue to up
that credit score as well there's
there's different parts of this equation
and so again playing that game over and
over and over at the far end it doesn't
get you to a point where you really can
build wealth fast in a sense from point
a to point b in the right way
um so i just wouldn't i wouldn't play
the credit score game i really wouldn't
brian if i if i woke up tomorrow and i
was you i'd pay off this credit card i
would see about the car lease which is a
whole other conversation figuring out
can you get out of it is there a buyout
where are you at in the car lease
get out of that focus yeah the child
support making sure that that's funded
and paid for and then start saving up uh
for your emergency fund and i would just
continue down the baby steps um because
again it is the plan that we have found
has created wealth for people uh and had
a level of getting out of this toxic
money culture that so many people are
stuck in and i just oh
and brian this is not at you it's not
disgusted at you i'm just the credit
card industry is just frustrating oh
it's frustrating keeping people in the
cycle of just
being in it and it's like and even on tv
i'm like you see all these commercials
all these celebrities and their promo
all cash back you know all this stuff
and i'm like speaking to
the population that's like okay
i'm going to pay extra money for a
middleman to use money that i don't have
and then you get stuck in it when you
actually look at people paying living
paycheck to paycheck
and you look at the interest rate on
these credit cards
up to 25
30 percent can be
and then
you look at the math and it's like and
that keeps compounding and if you miss a
payment and you don't pay it off in full
that interest is added on if you're
already living to paycheck to paycheck
you're already dug in a hole and they
just feed
the industry feeds off
of that part of the population and it
just makes me mad well there's a it is a
myth and they make so much money too by
the way america they're making so much
money it's a game and they're winning
but you know a mortgage company does not
care about your credit score they care
about how much down payment you have and
do you show a financial history where
you're stable he's going to be able to
say hey i paid off 7 500
in credit card debt i've got a 20 down
payment and that's why we here's my
income here's all my other bills oh my
cable myself that's what they're looking
at yeah they're not looking at credit
score and um you know it's
i
i don't have a credit score
you know i don't have a credit you don't
have one either so it's like but but no
one you know that doesn't mean that you
don't have financial stability and i
think that there's this cultural myth
that you look like a flake
when in all reality if you do what you
just told him to do brian brian if you
do what rachel said you're not going to
be looked at as a flake you're going to
look at somebody who yeah i'm happy to
give you a loan and here's the insane
thing about the credit score too to your
point that people believe like okay that
means i'm good it's like this number of
i'm good quote-unquote with manchester
united like a status somebody yeah and
i'm like brian great great
aunts dog walker julia who he doesn't
even know left him in her will yeah so
she dies tonight he wakes up tomorrow he
gets a phone call and he's there like
you've inherited six million dollars
your credit score is still exactly the
same number brian this is true she makes
a very good you could have a net worth
of millions of dollars more and it
doesn't change your credit like it's not
an indication that you're winning with
money it's an indication that you're
hanging out with the bank and just
in debt and doing all this oh i love it
i love angry rachel folks by the way
this is this is like her actual anger
it's not even real anger it's just like
it's like a character on saturday night
live and i'm here for kids you might see
my really well that may be true but
she's right
you're not a loser if you don't have a
credit score in fact you're not playing
in the matrix and that's a good thing
all right hang on we got to do these
things called commercials but rachel and
i will be back real soon this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
the ramsay show continues from our
ramsay solutions worldwide headquarters
in nashville i'm ken coleman rachel cruz
joins me this hour we're here for you
triple eight
eight two five five two two five that's
the toll-free number to jump in
um look i uh
i'm a man of the people rachel and i'm
always reading the news you know yes you
are ken trying to stay in touch
you are too
you're a woman a woman of the people we
we we have shows rachel cruz show the
ken coleman show's a part of the ramsey
network and so we're communicating with
our audience so i'm always reading the
news on what's relevant in the world of
work how's it affecting you so
the bottom line is this is scary to i
mean i look at the headlines and i
actually know what's going on yes i'm
reading everything and the fact is we're
in a baby recession yep um
we had an unbelievable jobs report in
july 500 000 jobs created we're at 3.5
unemployment it dropped a tenth of a
point okay so isn't it that amazing but
you would think that the world is coming
to an end for sure but i want to hear
from you because we haven't even talked
about this i'm sure you talk about it on
your show because i listened to
everything you got three kids
you got three kids and you're my friend
why would you listen ah ken okay so but
like ever so and like 2020 was an
absolute
change in the way i mean like it will be
down in history when you look to see
what came out of kovid the workforce
just changed completely
and so when we look now i'm like yeah
seeing all the job numbers which is
crazy during a recession because that's
usually the thing that gets hit
and then you're seeing all these new
ways and i even know even like teachers
right the teacher shortage that's going
on oh yeah and i'm like
it's just it does feel crazy though but
then the numbers are not lining up with
the crazy feeling that i'm having when
it comes to career does that make sense
it totally makes sense so what's going
on so well we've got this weird set of
things we've got some negatives in the
economy and some positives the negatives
are inflation obviously historic
inflation although we are starting to
see gas prices grocery prices are
starting to subside a little bit but
that's what we've been facing you've got
these weird dynamics of i'm hearing
about inflation i'm feeling it in my
wallet and then i start hearing about
recession and people just that's like a
it's like the boogeyman people freak out
yeah so that was one thing happening but
then over here you go wait a second
we've got record low unemployment 3.6 it
dropped to 3.5 in july we saw in may 370
some thousand jobs june 390 000 jobs
added and then july
500 000 stock market goes bongo this
morning when the report came out from
july so the stock market back up really
high so you get this weird dynamic where
the economy
is kind of bearish
but the stock market is back to the bull
and so it's like people are confused and
so what you're getting is all these
headlines designed to make you click so
you're like what's really going on and
here's what's going on wages are still
at an all-time high
you had another four million people quit
their jobs in july so bottom line is
it's not all bad
yeah i mean it's you're hearing negative
things all the time but if you look at
the actual economy it's a baby recession
so here's the point
you don't need to live in fear of the
headlines
but if you're at a point where you're
saying enough is enough and you're tired
of the headlines giving you kinds of
negative emotions about your money
you're going i can't control it well you
can control the controllables and we're
here to help you do that
so we want you to try financial peace
university the proven step-by-step plan
that has helped millions
get control of those controllables
that's you
and your habits if you follow our plan
you will be debt and build wealth the
only one who can say you can't is you so
if you've had enough stop living in fear
of the headlines and the politicians
take control of your money start fpu at
ramseysolutions.com
enough that's ramsey solutions
dot com slash enough chattanooga is
where we go next derrick is there derek
how can we help
hey guys thanks for taking the call how
are we doing today we're having a blast
what's going on with you
uh not much um so long story short i
discovered you guys about six months ago
and i think i'm on baby step six
uh i'm 32 i'm entirely debt-free
uh well not entirely i owe about 150 000
of my home
but i'm just really unsure of mainly
baby step five because i'm single with
no kids so do i just ignore that
and then really
what would be my path forward just keep
going how i am or do i need to change
something up yeah derek great job by the
way at 32 that's it's so impressive so
how much money do you make a year
uh 105 000. nice that's great what do
you do
i'm a project engineer okay very cool
yeah so to answer your question yet you
would skip baby step five um no need to
fund kids college at this point are you
investing into retirement 15 of your
income
i was
a few months ago i started a new job and
i'm not eligible for their 401k program
yet okay um but obviously once i get to
that point i plan on continuing
continuing the 15 into their 401k ira
with their company match yeah that's so
great and do you have a roth ira
open um
i don't have a personal one okay yeah
my pre my previous company they offered
a raw
yes okay yeah so there's the roth 401k
and then a roth ira which you'll just do
individually regardless of what business
you're at so that as long as you're
making an income uh that's another great
option to have because again it grows
tax-free
um it's another great place to put your
money if the 401k
um you take the match of that and then
anything other than i would go ahead and
max out your roth ira once you have
opened that and then go back to your
401k if there's any more of that 15 left
um so yeah so funding that focusing on
retirement skipping maybe step five and
then yeah throwing the rest at your
house derrick and um and getting that
paid off you know we always say you know
as soon as possible but it's not this
intensity that we talk about in baby
step two when you're paying off your
consumer debt so um but you're and i
would just encourage you to you're in a
great position just in your life stage
of being single not having kids to just
you know say hey if there's a margin i'm
gonna just throw it at the house because
if there is a marriage in your future
and kids in your future if that's
something you're wanting uh being set up
and and being able to go into those
seasons or if not but just the earlier
paying off that house i think is so
smart so you don't have to go crazy but
i also would would have an aggressive
goal to to pay it off and you make a
great income i mean 105 000. oh yeah a
year or something like that quick yeah
you could really really strip your
lifestyle down and just say hey i'm
gonna knock out that house and then
beyond that then derek yeah you're just
funding more into retirement investments
giving continuing to give even up in
your giving at that point in baby step
seven and enjoying some of your money
but you're doing you're doing exactly
what you should be doing so you're doing
great i would just encourage you to open
up a roth ira if you don't have a good
um investment professional in your life
i would find them we we recommend people
over the country they're smart vester
pros so you can go to
ramseysolutions.com and find one in your
area but i would recommend sitting down
with one of them and just
re-looking at your retirement making
sure that your money's going as far as
possible um and considering how young
you are you know the earlier you start
off you know you you really highlighted
the point here that he's going to have
so many options if and when kiddos come
along by paying off the house and being
young uh he's got some upward mobility
in the type of work he does as an
engineer so his better income days i
think are still ahead of him and you
know for parents are going oh you know
i'm getting this thing and i'm trying to
get control of the debt and i didn't put
enough in for the kids you know
if you just follow the baby steps and
get that financial piece it's going to
give you more options to be able to fund
things like the college if you're from
if you're behind you know or whatever
you need to do and uh you know he in his
case
wow i think the aggressive investing i
love that recommendation from you
because if he outside of
the 401k what you're suggesting i think
it's huge because the the wife and the
future kids i mean that gives him all
kinds of options where it doesn't even
affect him yep that's right that's right
so great great job derek yeah you've
done a great job you know so this this
again underscores if you're new to the
program and rachel we have new people as
you know joining all the time and
certainly a lot of young people we're so
excited we got a lot of young people
watching the show on youtube
and i think this is a key point you know
to encourage you specifically
that what we teach these baby steps baby
step one all the way through baby step
seven it gives you options
i i just don't think this this
generation you need to hear this it
gives you options lots of options it's
not just be financially disciplined or
whatever like grandma yeah you all want
options more than previous generations
and the
financial freedom what we call financial
peace i want you to hear
options baby
because that's what matters to you and
the way you want to live your life and
takes discipline it takes sacrifice it
takes patience but in the end tremendous
options all right uh stay tuned before
you know we'll be right back with more
of your calls america she's rachel cruz
i'm ken coleman this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm ken
coleman
my colleague joining me in the studio
today is rachel cruz we're ramsey
personalities we host shows on the
ramsay network but we are here for you
today taking your questions about money
and work they are inextricably tied
together that bigger shovel it's a
phrase we use to make more money to get
out of debt faster to save money to
invest more so i specialize in helping
people win in their work
and rates is going to help us win with
money today so if you are looking for a
breakthrough you just need somebody to
carefully guide you through some
practical steps to help you win we'd
love to be your guides today triple
eight eight two five five two two five
triple eight
eight two five five two two five abraham
is up in fort collins colorado abraham
how can we help
hey ken and rachel thanks for taking my
call sure um
so i'm a recent ramsay fan just this
summer
my wife and i have three kids and we
kind of made it to baby step two and
totally stalled out
um we are way upside down as far as how
much house we have and trying to get to
the next best step to extricate and and
keep moving forward
tell us about the house um
um so we bought our first starter house
six years ago for 230 and sold it for
315 so we did really well there bought
our next home for 439 and sold it for
4.95 two years later
we like to fix and flip then we got our
dream property here in colorado with
land and a home
but it was 680.
so we we made it i actually did a no-no
and pulled out my 401k during covid with
no penalties and put that enough to get
the down payment
it is now
about 48 of our income is our house
payment
yeah and we've been here two years and
it's it's a struggle and obviously we're
not we're not investing we're not doing
anything else but living so
the good news is we don't have we have
about three grand in credit card debt
that is it no other student loans or
other credit debt okay my question is i
know we need to probably get out from
under this
we could sell quickly and probably
get about 8.50
what we have remaining is 577 on the
house
or we could continue to do a little bit
more remodeling
maybe go into a little credit card debt
and hopefully get around 9 to 9 50 next
spring
i don't know well here's the only
question i have as tight as everything
is where are you going to get that
income
outside of the credit card that means
you're maxing out credit cards just to
be able to make these changes what's
your combined income is it just you
working
what what's your income situation
yeah my wife and i work i make about 105
a year and she makes about 20. she works
really part time so about 125.
um
i did buy my dream truck and oh i'm in
uh sales so i'm a sales territory sales
manager okay
what were you saying about your dream
truck
actually i did all the wrong things i
think along this process when we were in
our last home i bought my dream truck
brand new so that's three years old
that truck payment is about 500 a month
uh
what's that worth
uh i owe
about
33 on it and it's worth over 40. okay so
you do have other debt you said you just
had the credit cards so yeah that is
true okay yeah so the truck is gonna go
yeah what's the other car or what's it
do what's your other loan on the car on
the other car um
the other car we own is paid off it's
paid
off
no like personal loans no 401k loans i
know you cashed it out to do i was
making sure nothing else okay
so yeah
the truck and the
yes
so here's what so
um
not fascinating it's probably the wrong
word abraham to use but
our homes you know people go into a home
um and like you said it's our dream home
and it sounds amazing right you get land
in colorado you get a home all of it
like it's it is a it's a sacred place to
people because it's where your kids are
it's where your family is i mean your
home is just such a cherished place
and what ends up happening is this thing
that we thought was such a blessing ends
up being the absolute biggest burden to
you and your wife like
i could imagine you are you're stressed
out you're thinking about it all the
time
when you want to go do something fun
it's like we have no money too i mean
it's just it is a constant
sore spot in your life and so this thing
that you thought was going to be such a
cherished wonderful
dreamy
part of your life ends up being this
burden and so that happens to so many
people abraham like i'm not that's not a
shameful thing to say to you but that's
the reality and where a lot of people
are
um so yeah if i were you guys how old
are your kids
uh they're ten eight and four okay yeah
so you got little ones so
i mean so if i if i'm you i am relieving
as much stress as possible in my life
and doing renovations going into debt
for renovations all that adds way more
stress because stuff takes longer than
you expect it's always more expensive
and you're going to use debt which is
not even going to be an option that
we're going to give you so
um if i were you abraham i would i and i
know it hurts but i would i would sell
and i would find i would find a home
that you guys go back to that it's like
okay it's you know it's reasonably 25 of
our take-home pay uh you sell the truck
you pay off this debt you guys get an
emergency fund you get back on solid
footing and something else happens too
during this process there's a level of
realizing
man our priorities have just shifted i
would rather be in a smaller space with
peace of mind and i'm not losing sleep
at night than to have what i thought i
wanted and be stressed out and so
i would i would sell and i would i would
find something that you guys can afford
and and then the great thing too abraham
is you could look up in a few years and
and go get land again it's not like that
this is the only time you never could or
that you can in that truck you can
always go buy that truck again in a few
years your dream truck like all of this
whole thing of
being debt-free and getting a firm
foundation doesn't mean you can never
enjoy stuff or go back to the dreams
that you had you can always go back to
them but you're gonna do it where those
dreams
are are a blessing it's a gift in your
life it doesn't take away from your life
and so what's happened is um is it's
been hard for you guys i can only
imagine so
um i hate to say sell it because i know
it's a dream of you guys to have lands
in a house but it's just it's and i
don't see your income going up or her
going back i wouldn't i wouldn't send
her back to work full-time unless she
wanted to to pay for a house payment
like i would not yeah i agree it's not
worth it it's just not worth it well you
better you gotta get rid of the truck
and the credit card in this whole deal
all right so like this is an all-in get
rid of all of it so you know you're
gonna have what seven grand and some
change left if you sell the truck
and you can get a decent older suv for
that that's just what you're going to
have to do
you know well the blessing is actually
my job came with a company vehicle so i
don't actually need to replace my truck
so that's a really good thing okay so
now okay so now we take the profit from
the truck and we wipe out the credit
cards if i remember that amount
correctly so now okay about three yeah
so let's just play some real fun math
here how much is that going to free up
in your budget
if we pay off the truck today and the
credit cards today what's the we got 500
a month on the truck what's on the
credit card right now minimum payments
uh minimum payments on the card are
about 80 bucks all right so okay 580
bucks but that's 580 bucks that's over
six thousand dollars a year
immediately yep you sell the house and
here's the thing i want you to hear and
dave's a great example you just use dave
ramsey's example so dave was in real
estate he was doing very well right if
you don't know dave's story the bank
called all the notes rachel's a baby you
know it and he loses everything right
but dave went back and got into real
estate
even bigger than ever and it's all cash
so you all have experience see dave had
experience and i've heard him say to me
before he's like it's easier to make the
second million than it was the first
and you all have some knowledge you
flipped i think you said two houses
prior to this one so rachel made a very
good point i want to drive that home
yes this is a bit of a contraction
but it's temporary and now you're going
to come out of this be completely debt
free
no stress on mama you the three kids
and then you can start that flipping
process if you want to get back into
that one day but this time you do it all
cash because you know how to do it
you've been there before so i just want
you to be encouraged
in the midst of this pain because this
is
painful and i just want to acknowledge
that this is going to suck to sell this
house
you know it is it feels like a step back
which is hard for me but yes i
understand it well let's be let's be
honest it is a step back but it will
position you to make so many more steps
forward faster
that's the key you got to remember that
right now because it is a step back
don't try to sugarcoat it but it's going
to position you and you're going to come
back better
and stronger than before and you're you
guys are functioning in such a tight
budget already that when you free it up
even moving homes your priorities may
shift you may realize huh what other
options do we have we talked about
options earlier so abraham you're a
great dad great husband and i think you
guys are making some hard decisions but
in
nine months after everything's cleared
and done you're gonna breathe again and
sleep at night she's rachel cruz i'm ken
coleman thank you america for joining us
here on the ramsay show
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsey show it's
where we talk to america about their
life their money their work and their
relationships i'm ken coleman rachel
cruz joins me this hour we are here for
you triple eight eight two five five two
two five triple eight
eight two five
five
two two five let's go to the motor city
to start this hour off mitchell is there
in detroit mitchell how can we help
hi um so i'm trying to decide if i
should focus my energy and attention on
the career i currently have or switch
over to
the business that i currently have so i
i currently work as an automation
technician and i work for a great
company that is very loyal to me and
supporting me and they're they're
sending me to college um they're dying
but i have a contract with them for five
years so i i have a commitment to this
company
and uh i do really love this company and
i think it's full of great people but um
i read i read your book
ken from paycheck to purpose and
the part where you talked about getting
clear with yourself
really
uh
i don't know i just had an epiphany and
i kind of thought that
i'm not so sure that this is what i want
to be doing for the rest of my life and
i just have this
this inner passion for owning my own
business and i i can't help but feeling
like
i owe it to society in our world to
bring put my best skills forward
and do what i think i am the most
passionate about how old are you
mitchell i currently
i'm 20. you're 20. and tell me about the
side business
so the business that i currently have is
essentially like a marketing agency i
make ads for
what is it's right right now i only make
ads for my own company i
i
i get with i it's so to flash my
business i have suppliers and i like go
out and find suppliers that have very
high quality flashlights bring them to
the us and then basically act as their
marketing agent
how much money
send me how long you've been doing it
how much money are you averaging a month
from this side business
so i launched the website about a month
ago and i've probably made about a
thousand dollars okay great well first
of all i love your enthusiasm and your
passion and you read correctly that is
what i want you to do and i do think
that you have a unique contribution to
make however
um i was once 20 it's hard to believe
when i say that when you said mitchell
from the motor city i thought oh his 20
year old days were yeah far away it's a
very old man called that's what they
call detroit
no it isn't very much just a grandpa
move that's fine
okay that's fine i can handle it uh
anyway mitchell you're 20 right and so
um you've got a lot of time and you also
get this this contract
how far into the five-year commitment do
you have to this company that they're
paying for your schooling
i'm halfway through the program so i'm
two and a half years in great great
schooling is three years and then i have
two years of full-time employment at the
company and and just so you know i am
fully committed to finishing out right
five years so so here's the
encouragement right no matter what okay
great because that's the right move
um and i also love the idea of you being
20 and you started this thing and you're
a month in because the reality is six
months from now you may have another
idea
uh and that's okay too at 21 or 20.
this is the season where you've got a
stable job
the great news you like the work you
like the people and there's tremendous
stability here so this is the season of
testing and and exploring ideas
so my advice is stay the course
let's try a lot of things what you got
to be careful of here
is that you don't let your heart
kind of drown out your brain here and
and talk you out of if you get some
success with this this marketing agency
and sort of go oh i want it no stay the
course uh build it to the pace that you
can build it given you've got
responsibilities with school and work
and let's just see what else comes in my
into mind as you think about the future
um but there is a day coming i can see
it where you will be your own boss and
work for yourself but
you got to replace that income
you've got to replace the income and so
that's always the mindset uh it's very
easy for young people specifically to
obsess about the next and miss what you
need to do in the now
and then ultimately sacrifice the next
so that's my only caution you got a
really level head i think you got a
really good plan rachel any thoughts
here yeah
you sound
extremely mature yeah uh to be a 20 year
old so i think that yeah and i think
like can saying continue to grow and i
think even you know you already said
this but honoring that time with the
company and the investment they're
putting in you taking you through school
and all of that and even that in itself
is a good character move like when you
can learn to keep your word early on
that's right uh and stay the course like
ken is saying there's even a character
quality to that mitchell of uh that's a
great value of great value so um yeah i
think i think you're doing awesome and
like ken said i think
we're going to look down the future
mitchell will have his own company at
some point in life for sure patience is
a superpower i wish i'd have known that
at 20. patience it really does pay off
all right so here's another uh let's see
if this is another grandpa move your
words let's go north let's go north of
the border you said that earlier too but
i'm going to say it again because that's
where it is toronto canada
elizabeth is there elizabeth how can we
help hi
hi ken and rachel
greetings from the sunny toronto sunny
and dry toronto well that's nice because
it is wet here in nashville today so
that's exactly why i'm so excited you're
dry over here we're boasting from the
night that we have sun and dryness
that's fantastic how can we help you
today elizabeth so um i want to know
whether or not i should pay off my
mortgage or my heloc and i know ramsey
says pay off the heloc but that's the
only two debt i have
and i was focusing on paying off the
heloc until i ran into a snag this yeah
today where um
i maxed out the amount that i could pay
within one year which is 15
and
i can't do anything more with the heloc
because i locked in for five years
variable rate it's now at 3.58
and
this is where we're at now the mortgage
on the other hand
so the heloc i have 79
389 left on that 79 thousand 39
and the mortgage i have 129
fives
on that
and my mortgage is coming due um
december 1st 2022
the rate is a locked rate at 2.54
so i don't know
what to do right now
um with these two i know he says pay off
the heloc but where we're at right now
i'm a little stumped because i can't pay
anything more without paying a penalty
on the heloc of that going over was
there an option elizabeth to roll it
into your mortgage
there is an option in december yeah you
could looking to do that because you
could do that but
yeah you'll be paying both debts off and
it'll be a lower interest rate if you do
that we always say to pay off the heloc
if and put it in baby step two if it's
half of your annual income but all the
math that you're that you're throwing at
me i'm assuming that's probably not the
case so if you can just roll it into
your mortgage that's an option to get a
lower interest rate and then attack it
but you're doing you're doing great
elizabeth
thanks so much thanks for the call thank
you so much for the call by the way i
like the way she said your name i'm mike
i might call you rachel i love it the
rest of the show i like it because i'm
north of the border canyon
things that irritate right rochelle
so fun hey don't move more of the ravens
show coming up
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free
whitepaper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm ken
coleman rachel cruz joins me this hour
as we take your calls triple eight eight
two five
five two two five that is the toll-free
number dalton is up in san antonio texas
dalton how can we help
hey guys first off thank you so much for
taking my call really love the show love
all you all thanks my question is this
yes no problem my question is this
should i stay in my current sales job as
an rv salesman or should i go back to
school
and
pursue law school okay so
what's on the other side of law school
for you what does that look like that
vision
so
i uh have been passionate about
uh justice and law
and so
a career that i can actually see myself
doing
and
being able to help people
not only that it's
also something i can make money doing
and so also
the vision there is i mean i don't want
to limit myself
but
because i know there are several
different pathways once you become an
attorney
but
probably going to try to focus on
helping veterans out
sure all right so i just wanted to hear
your heart behind it you know because
when somebody asked me a question like
that it's it's like well if you want to
be a lawyer you got to go to law school
and i am no fan of grad school for just
for the sake of burnishing your resume
but in this case it's obviously relevant
you got to do it uh so the question is
what what do you have saved
um because i have an idea for you that i
don't think most people know about i had
the privilege of interviewing a guy
who's a lawyer who wrote this small
little booklet and blew my mind about
how you can go to law school for free
and i'm going to tell you about that in
a second but i want to know what's your
target schools what kind of money do you
have set aside because we don't want you
to go into debt and law school can be
unbelievably expensive
gosh you got [ __ ] so
i um actually don't have any debt i'm on
baby step three
um
saving my emergency fund working on that
the
thing is is my grandmother when she
passed away she left
in her 401k
a certain amount of money that my dad
actually has access to every year and
that is what is helping pay off my
brothers my sisters and eventually will
help pay off my
student loans by god's grace yeah well
but i still don't want you to i would
rather that money maybe go towards
paying for some of the school and cash
flowing sure so let me tell you about
this and you got to do your homework
okay so you're going to have to do your
homework on law schools that you're
interested in but here's the simple
process
there are all of the big shiny
impressive like vanderbilt law or
harvard law
but there are you wouldn't believe like
all the state schools
uh smaller schools that you've never
heard of that have law programs
and if you score a certain number and
it's very high so you can go do the
research this is readily available
on the lsat which is the entrance exam
for law school
certain scores and you can take the lsat
by the way dalton as many times as you
want
and i that to me would be the play
because if you get a certain score law
schools will ask you to come to their
law school and give you a full ride and
the reason is because they're looking to
put out successful lawyers so i want you
to know that's not some scheme that's
not a a pipe dream that's real and i
would really implore you to think about
that because here's what i know rachel
um i've not had to deal with lawyers
very much had to hire a lawyer a few
times on just contract stuff nothing big
but you know what i've never asked them
where they went to law school yeah yeah
same with doctors yeah right last time
you went and got a checkpoint on you're
like i didn't start okay okay it wasn't
like well if you didn't go to one of
these three squares right right as
they're rolling you back to the er yeah
right or the operating room and you're
like yeah nobody cares so dalton that's
what i i want the money
first of all go get really clear with
your dad
what's the allocation for me
for law school and instead of thinking
about applying that to a loan how about
we apply that to any tuition or maybe
housing or something you might need to
make this transition so that's what i
want you to hear yes you should go to
law school don't rush
all right because law school's going to
be there
the veterans and the people you want to
help with that law degree are going to
be there so i'd get my ducks in a row is
what i'm saying here and i would really
really encourage you if you're a good
student and a good test taker i was not
but if you are that's a viable option to
save
and it's just a crazy amount of money
yeah for you is what's more of the
motivation helping veterans in life or
is it more being a lawyer
so
and it could be both i guess you could
say both yeah
so that's a great question um
i am a veteran myself
and
short story long i had a lot of things
happen to me and
was administratively discharged from the
air force and i just got off the phone
with an attorney
and
they with the south texas college of law
and she told me that they are going to
be able to take my case for free this
semester to help me get that all
situated and all fixed up and
after getting off that call it was a
confirmation if i could do that one day
for another veteran or even even if i
could do that one day for someone else
who's struggling
with any type of situation
or legal matter it it would make the
world of difference yeah
dalton forgive the ignorance of this if
it's an ignorant question but does the
gi bill not come into play for you on
law school
so
it's it's up in the air after getting
off that phone call with that attorney
it it's looking like i have a lot
greater chances of being able to use
that gi bill okay but if you were taking
off for leave then yeah that's part of
what's going on okay i got you all right
that makes sense yeah
that's the full story i asked that
question dalton as i'm like you know not
steering you away from law school by any
means
um but continuing to look at options we
talk about options on the show all the
time but like where's a way that i can
do that and help in a way um that may
not require a law degree like is is that
an option at all because law school it's
expensive it's long all of that but if
being a lawyer is
and the legal system is a real big
passion of yours then obviously you need
to go but i just wanted to
clarify and make sure that um
that you can't get that passion served
in other positions besides just being a
lawyer but it's great and i hope that it
all goes uh in your favor for sure yeah
uh because that will help with yeah the
gi bill that's a great co-op dalton
thank you so much for your service yes
yes thank you for the call let's go to
gabriel in fort worth texas gabriel how
can we help
honey
yeah so i've got a pretty good question
for you guys we're
i'm
trying to figure out if i should sell
our house
to pay off our debt
or to stay in the home and find a job
that would help you know kind of pay
toward the debt faster and if i chose
the job site i'd go from corporate style
to a startup business
okay
how much is your mortgage payment a
month percentage-wise for your overall
budget
uh it's 20 yeah 25 so it's 15.75
okay
and i i make 90 000 a year okay yeah i
mean selling the hat i mean especially
since
it's not a huge part of your budget
which is great it's what we teach that
it doesn't eat into everything that um
and how much sorry how much debt do you
guys have
we have 22 000 in car which is one
vehicle and then 6 000 in medical how
much could you sell the car
more than that more than the 22. why
would you just get rid of the cars
yeah probably 32 000 so 32 and it's you
could you could
sell it knock everything out and have
four grand hanging around
knock out your all your debt
yeah and that way i guess we wouldn't
have to have a
sell the home or yes yeah
and i don't i do not like you trying to
make more money with a startup
that's too risky okay and it's
unnecessary yeah your house payment's
not out of control no it's not the house
the house isn't the issue it's it's you
guys buckling down are you guys on a
strict budget are you are you sitting
down before the month begins okay you
know exactly where your money's going
okay that's great sell the car oh yeah
i'd get rid of that
get rid of it
yeah i i would i mean you owe 22 000 you
get 32 for it
you gain 10 pay off the credit cards at
six
have four left how are you driving
around a clunker for a while who cares
use that four to throw towards something
else save employee you make great income
yeah don't sell no you don't need to
sell the house get real yeah thank you
so much for the call you guys are so
close
stay the course thank you so much for
the call all right folks don't move more
the ramsay show coming right up
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show thrilled
to have you with us i'm ken coleman
rachel cruz joins me as we are here
taking your calls triple eight eight two
five five two two five we're talking
about your life whether that's your
money situation your work situation
uh we are here to help today let's go to
ogden utah connor is there connor how
can we help
uh yeah thank you for taking my call
um
so
my wife and i are about ready to
move out of our home we have a little
daughter and we're outgrowing it um so
i've been looking at our options and
because my parents are
so generous and we've been so blessed uh
they told us about a week ago that
they're going to be giving all their
kids an inheritance early so they could
watch him spend it and the inheritance
is about three hundred thousand dollars
wow
yeah that's awesome and so
that opens up a lot of options for us uh
we have been kind of weighing in our
heads and one of the things is that our
current home is in a college town and
we've been thinking about maybe just
paying that off with a hundred thousand
or 115 000 is what we we owe on it still
um
and then renting it out and then using
the other 200 000 as a down payment to
our next house which would
give us a comfortable house payment um
but the other option is we thought maybe
we would just sell this house now
and take the 200 000 in equity and put
it towards our next down payment along
with
300 000 or whatever to to basically buy
our next house and in cash and not have
a house payment so we're just trying to
figure out between those two options
what what would maybe there's another
option that i'm not thinking about
either that you can fill me in on
um
no not off not off the top of my head of
what you guys want to do i mean i think
this is a really smart move and i think
a beautiful way to honor your parents
and the
the legacy and the inheritance that
they're giving you i'm sure they would
appreciate
seeing this versus
taking
18 trips around the world or something i
mean i don't know there's something
about it that is like oh there's like a
civility it's an investment um
i'm curious to know are you two leaning
the same way one of you leaning one way
one leaning the other
my wife is leaning a little bit towards
the renting
and and i'm kind of honestly in the
middle i could see it either way i like
the idea of having that extra stream of
income coming in every single month
um but there's also that feeling of just
not having any debt at all with our next
home yeah and just being free and clear
connor do you all want to be landlords
like the idea of an investment property
sounds like oh that sounds great and yes
there's passive income and i come from a
real estate family my husband loves real
estate it's like i get it
but because of that i also know all of
the work that goes in and then you said
college town that i'm sure you can find
a great group of college students to
rent it out but you're also renting it
out to college students so
um or possibly you could obviously not
do that but i mean the landlord thing
it's that's not just a oh yeah that's
cool and fun i mean it ends up kind of
being a part-time job and if you're
working full-time i'll be honest it may
land into your wife's lap of her having
to go and fix this the sink breaks and
they you know like it's it's a
it's a thing too so i just want you guys
to keep in mind so it is a great a great
way to have um
passive income but if i were you i would
just be free and clear and then if you
guys want to
save up because you won't have a
mortgage if you just
sold it
and um
and then paid cash for your primary
residence
yeah i mean that's that's phenomenal
then you could save up a lot and if you
guys chose to go into real estate
investing then then you could and start
small uh maybe even a different location
right yeah like so so it's a fun little
exercise how much do you think you could
get
per month for that house in the college
town if you paid it off with some of
this inheritance how much
13.50 is about what the rent would be
okay so again you know what's that going
to end up being uh 18 19 000 20 000 i'm
not really great at math but somewhere
in that range right
uh 15 16 something like so you have to
sit there with your wife and okay here's
the income that this would spit off but
that doesn't include the expenses that
rachel was touching that it's not going
to be free and clear 15 to 18 000
dollars you have to replace carpet in
three years you're going to probably
repaint the wall i mean it's just i
think that's i learned that one from
george i was with george george campbell
threw that at a caller the other day i
was like that's a really good exercise
because it's like is it worse is it
worth all the work let's just call it
net just for easy numbers
14 000 a year you're gonna have expenses
you're just going to and
you've got all of this for 14 grand and
to rachel's point like what's the
trade-off
on like a huge down payment or buying
buying a house cash
you know in this point in your marriage
so i'd get rid of the house too
i really would okay
it's just uh but you got to sit down
with your wife at casper and there's not
i don't think there's a wrong answer
here that's correct something cause one
of them's gonna be paid off if you were
gonna still have debt on an and debt on
a primary residence i would tell you to
get rid of it hands down but
uh for it being paid off there's not
yeah it's not right or wrong it's just
truly where you guys want to put your
time and your efforts you know if it's
if it's
my dad or my husband they're probably
going to keep it because they love real
estate and they're like oh it is worth
it because of you know they just it's
part of what they love but to me i'm
like
and to call it oh man i just remember
the rhymer renting a house in college
winston lived with like six guys in our
own house it was disgusting
it was terrible oh yeah block parties
games and all that kind of stuff yeah we
were good renters though my group of my
my group of friends we were very clean
we we took care of that house
we were i was an old soul yeah
well in the college days yeah i think
you're still an old soul oh not as old
as me though apparently with my little
friends north of the border
melissa's up in chattanooga tennessee
don't get me started on chattanooga
melissa how can we help
hi rachel hi ken it is a pleasure to
speak with you today i'm so grateful
um i'm in a situation now um i have a
possible fork in my career path and i'm
hoping you can kind of help me unpack it
a little bit sure
so what's going on i had my quarterly
check in with my supervisor today now
it's kind of a back story we work for a
big company who has two retail locations
i work for the smaller of the two and
it's quite a bit smaller and i manage i
oversee it and i have three teammates
who work for me and so we've been
working really really hard for a few
years now even through covet and all of
that on expanding growing providing more
service for people
and what's the point where the the
company or the building that we rent
we have a possibly having our lease
being bought out by somebody else who
shares the building
now we're not in a position where we can
rent a new location we've got a really
sweet deal with this building so what it
sounds like i've got probably a 60 to 75
chance that we are going to close my
location
and we are going to be absorbed into the
bigger location my teammates will blend
just fine the thing that we run into is
my position um my director is super
awesome super supportive and really
thinks that there is a path of
progression for me to take her position
and as she plans to exit the company in
the next two to three years
i
i'm not so confident but i'm also kind
of interested i think maybe it would be
a huge leap from assistant manager to
director
um but i'm just not sure what what i
want to think right now
so what would be
yeah i get it so what would the interim
look like so if they shut this down the
smaller location where you're in a
manager position
and and then you go to the bigger
location you're underneath that director
what role are you in are you making the
same amount of money
and we just started discussing that it
would be a new role created for me sort
of a gm in training
along with whatever else so i actually
get a legit paycheck with a legit job at
the other location while i'm training
and and helping
helping that business grow but also
learning the rotation
to be a director okay if you knew
that the path was two to three years it
was guaranteed you were going to replace
her would you be on the phone with us
i'm pretty sure it could happen i'm just
not sure if it's the right choice
for me that's what i'm asking okay so
so yeah okay so you're not sure if
that's the long-term play for you
and i love that so uh how soon is a
decision gonna be made where you're
gonna have to choose i've got about 30
seconds so give me the quick answer um
we're looking at probably end of year
we'll know what's going to happen with
the leaf all right so here's what i
would decide if i'm staying or going all
right so here's what i would do i would
spend time right now thinking about your
long-term future knowing that you have a
safe option to at least take this for
the interim while you still figure this
out okay so i just want you to breathe
stay with the company until you figure
it out long term hang on the line let's
get you an assessment get clear career
assessment i'll give that to you a link
in a code i want you to take that as you
consider long term what your options are
but i'm glad you're stable right now
thank you for the call this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back america you are listening
to the ramsay show i'm ken coleman
rachel cruz joins me in studio as we
take your calls this hour now folks
you're hearing a lot of
people in the news the talking heads
you're reading headlines
about the real estate market and if you
believe them you're going to think oh
the housing market's going to crash it's
going to be a repeat of the 2008 housing
crisis but i can tell you you're not
hearing the truth you can't make
decisions based on fear you need the
facts and here they are in 2008 there
was a massive supply of homes but not
enough buyer demand so
home prices dropped but that's not
what's happening in today's market right
now there are half as many homes for
sale and twice as many buyers this means
the home values while you may see prices
coming off of the inflated prices but
values aren't going down
so if you're ready to buy or sell a home
you don't have to wait you can still win
in this market but you got to work with
somebody who actually knows the market
and make sure that you've got a guide
to walk you through the process and
we've done the hard work here at ramsey
solutions to vet agents that know your
local market and have the experience of
transactions to back up their advice to
connect with one of our ramsey trusted
agents for free go to
ramseysolutions.com
agent
that's ramsey solutions.com
agent alyssa is up in redding california
alyssa how can we help
hey guys things are taking my call how
are you doing today we're having a blast
what's going on
um so me and my fiance i'm excited today
we're getting married october 1st hey
congratulations
yes
thank you so we're kind of prepping up
our lives
um we both finished the the three baby
steps um we are ready to like start
going to town on like saving up all of
our money towards a down payment we just
finished up paying off our wedding so
we're good to go
um we
thank you yeah the only thing that the
only problem we have here is um well
that problem just we need to figure out
what to do is in january jacob is
changing his uh he's going through his
credentialing program so he'll be
starting as a student teacher for six
months he will not be getting paid he
just works 40 hours a week and doesn't
get paid so
we're planning for that because we're
like okay well what do we need to do
then i make twenty six hundred dollars a
month like as far as like after taxes
come out after i save my fifteen percent
towards retirement i have twenty six
hundred dollars um we're currently
looking for a place to settle down to
together as our first home um so we're
looking at a place for 1500
we we're trying to figure out kind of
how much we should also
we both have three months saved of
emergency fund so we're kind of figuring
out what should our strategy be should
we like stockpile it up to six months
and then like i don't know we're kind of
looking for strategy here if you guys
have any um what's the number you said
you both have you said you both have
emergency funds what's in each of your
funds
so four thousand for each of us
for each so so eight thousand total
eight total do you guys have any debt
no debt no debt okay and what would his
income be again you may have said it uh
what would it i know he's without income
for six months starting in january
what what income has he been making up
to this point per month right now he
can't uh uh i think he's got five
thousand gross but we can save 37 to 4
dollars off his paycheck they fluctuate
through the end of december
great okay for his living expenses great
and i can save one thousand so i'm sorry
he's twenty together sorry he can do
twenty seven to thirty seven hundred
days of after living expenses i could do
one thousand so together after we live
we can save 37 to 4 700 through december
on our paycheck great can i set you up
for that next six months yeah that's
just kind of the yeah i would have a
separate i would have the i would have
the 8 000
just brielle's emergency fund and then
whatever money you guys have saved
you're going to earmark that right 15 20
000 whatever it ends up being at the end
of the year
and then that's where you that you're
and you need to run out your numbers too
um as much as you can figure out okay
how do we
um look at our expenses once we're
married and how much per month will we
need
uh and make sure that that total number
is okay and that can just kind of be
like your side bank that you're just
pulling money out each month and you've
got to be really diligent about it um
but also i mean the numbers you gave to
besides the savings it's around 1100
left after yeah i think there's a little
bit more hustle involved here so i'm
just wondering for him at night at night
what's he gonna be doing after hours and
you guys are gonna be newly married and
so like it's not fun but there's a
little bit of this like
adult life of like hey i've chosen this
track and i'm gonna do that that doesn't
mean at four o'clock when he's on
student teaching that y'all just are
gonna hang out he's probably gonna have
a job you're not coming home and
watching judge judy you know you're
probably gonna be working at night like
maybe you know at least four times a
week or something and i would say even
now i think there's two choices yeah
that's a good point i i if if he's
sitting here with me i'm putting arm
around him saying hey man uh you need to
go all in right now before the wedding
you're working crazy hours stocking up
what that six month number needs to be
yeah based on what rachel said she's
right that living expense budget what do
we need so that we're not stressing that
six months the last thing you all want
is to be newlyweds and he's starting a
new career which is already hard yeah
okay and and and he's not getting paid
even though he knows he's paying his
dues this is all psychology well that
analogy then you're struggling i would
not be buying a house either i would be
right no i would rent i would be renting
so so rent rent rent
don't don't be a homeowner right now
during all of this because you guys are
newly married number one number two this
added stress of what could come up that
you guys wouldn't be able to cover yeah
uh if something comes up in the house
versus where a landlord can i mean
you're gonna be
so finding place to rent um
and you know it's funny i was talking to
george campbell actually uh right before
the show and we're talking about we were
laughing because we're like hgtv ruins
our generation
as much as we love
you know why is that because of our
expectations now of what a house has to
be and what it should be and then you
can add in right uh social media in the
middle of that instagram but what houses
and living
is like today versus like even you know
george and i which we were you're you're
an elder here at the table compared to
me ken all the shots of my age today but
in the 90s you know when i grew up in
the early 90s like i know what our house
was like as kids paper thin doors your
bathrooms you shared it was tiny it's so
true like it just was i remember those
doors and so you just like that was life
then that was normal and now the
expectation so listen i'm saying all
this to say
when you are newlyweds
there is a an even heightened uh
emotional pull towards we want to create
a beautiful home and have like all of
this and it's just so beautiful
which yes you want your space to be
great but don't have a have a big a look
in the mirror and just say we are going
to have contentment with this
and we're going to be smart we're not
going to go financially
in the hole and make a stupid move on a
house when we can't afford it
uh just to live in that level of like
what it should be and what you think it
is you know what i mean like there's i
agree with you this is the adventure
time live live in a room over garage
with some old lady owns or something and
save even more money let your husband
move into that student teaching thing
with zero stress and you all focus on
your relationship this is the i mean i
remember my mom and dad were in town
recently and these stories i hope we
don't do this to our kids they were like
you will well we lived in a 900 square
foot my dad doesn't even talk like that
i don't know why i'm doing that voice
but you know we live in a 900 square
foot apartment over top of a pharmacy
you know i'm like like i'm supposed to
react to that i don't remember it but
you think about that 900 square feet
yeah two
two room apartment they said two room it
was like
it was their bedroom and then everything
else was like i think the bathroom and
the kitchen was all like right there yep
and you think about that you go okay
i mean the jury's out whether or not i
turned out okay i mean i realize now the
skeptics but yeah you know we survived
yeah and i don't even remember that yes
and certainly as a as a newlywed couple
with no kids yes
just don't get into the newlywed
romanticizing about the living situation
i like what you said about htv you know
we need to be telling these young
couples go for the before house not the
after house oh ken huh i'm trying to pay
attention i'm trying to be involved with
this younger thing you're doing that i
like that so instead of the flip instead
of the other side go to the first house
i know go to the before
get stable then maybe you could flip it
down the line yeah for sure i know i do
love hgtv though no it's great we were
kind of just joking we were like chip
and joe you know we love them obsessed
but also they ruined us with shiplap we
just feel like everything you need to be
like forever even though i feel like
that's even fading right is it i think
so a little bit whereas ken was just
thankful to have running water in his
log cabin
yeah i looked at a log cabin i'm so glad
that you were concerned about shipping
i grew up eating it
go research spam all you young
20-somethings i ate that hamburger
helper oh that's not spam like spam
wouldn't have cleared usda
qualifications
hey fam it's been a fun hour thanks to
the team in the booth thanks to you
america she's rachel cruz i'm ken
coleman and this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's rachel cruz co-host on the
ramsay show if you want to do your
debt-free stream live on the show visit
ramseysolutions.com
debt free screen we'd love for you to
come to nashville and tell dave your
story that's ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of ramsay
solutions this is the ramsey show it's
where we talk about your life your money
your work
and your relationships i'm ken coleman
rachel cruz joins me this hour and we
are here for you to take your calls
america the phone number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five triple
eight eight two five
five
two two five let's go to moss point
mississippi
that's where linda is waiting linda how
can we help
yes i
i've got
almost a hundred thousand dollars in my
checking account
at the bank
and i'm
kind of
i'm 60 or 76 years old
and i'm getting kind of nervous
how
i've been looking at
gold and silver and stuff you know what
would you do with that money instead of
having it in the bank all that money
tell us what you're most nervous about
uh
i don't trust the government come on all
right welcome to the club linda
welcome to the club you and i can wear
the same hat um so so play that out a
little bit um i don't trust the
government either
but what what are you what is a a really
uh serious concern and fear that's
making you call us right now or you
think they're going to raid your bank
account what's going on here right yes
what would cause them to do that
well
because
the way he's spending money he's going
to figure he needs some more money okay
all right okay
all right i see what you're saying
rachel what's what are some options here
so linda i love your line of thought and
everyone that knows a little bit of me i
just love a good conspiracy theory so
i've been down every rabbit hole you can
imagine um
but i think though linda um the truth is
if that really did happen
i think a war would break out
if the government came in and started
taking people's money yeah from their
personal
savings and checking account
we have other problem like it would it
just i just don't i genuinely
don't see that happening personally yeah
could i mean could you make a case for
it linda
uh
sure it it could they can drum up any
kind of reasons i mean they really could
do just about anything they wanted to do
do i think that's gonna happen
yeah but linda i don't think you need to
be worried about that right now i would
and i don't want you to be investing in
gold or silver no yeah commodities like
that linda they don't they don't hold
their value and do you have any any
investments linda that you
are living off of is it like from
previous retirement or anything or is it
just that money in the bank that is is
your nest egg
no i i i make about uh eight thousand
dollars a month income i sold some
properties okay you know so i got lots
of income yeah but i just been nervous
about uh
you know i even thought about
putting it in in a safe you know
but
i don't think that's right
you know yeah that's the last thing you
want is everybody in your community
seeing a big old truck coming in with a
safe
hey what's going on over at linda's
house
right
yeah right do you have a financial
advisor
no i don't i really recommend um you
trusted us enough to call the show today
i i really recommend that you get on our
website ramseysolutions.com
and i would love for you to to seek out
on our website smart investor pros these
are men and women that we vetted out
because of their values they understand
how
dave for three decades has treated
people and and they're gonna coach you
and and you can interview them you don't
have to choose the first one that you
meet with meet with several in your area
but just really explain some of your
worries and your your concerns and some
ways to protect yourself and i think
that it will just show you several
things number one your options um and
and and then number two just what would
have to happen for those fears of yours
to come true what your protections are
what you can do how can diversify some
of that money because you've got really
good income coming in yeah i would even
talk to them about
offshore accounts and things of that
nature i'm no expert on that but the
bottom line is they know about
investment opportunities things like
where you can protect your money you
know from things like this and you
invest your money you know i'm just
saying i'd look into it i'm not an
expert i talked to one of our smart
investor pros about it rachel's freaking
out right now
it's a way to protect your money i mean
it's it's people do this they invest it
and it's it's it is a thing
and i thought you know
i'm getting to the point where i i worry
i'm
worried about my money you know yeah uh
and i i'm a widow so i
i got no husband to
advise me you know well let me let me
tell you this too linda that um
you know we say around here a lot that
um there's been a lot of fear
in our economy and in our culture over
the past few years i feel like it's just
risen
um for multiple reasons and we just
never make decisions out of fear
usually when decisions are made
completely out of fear it's in the short
term
um to
rest aside that fear but in the long
term when you look out you know
three four five years it's not always
the best decision but you made it kind
of in a vacuum out of fear so i really
um
want to just give you peace that you
know if something we're and we're in
this industry all the time so we're
talking to people we're seeing things
going on we're reading the news
all of it and if something fell off like
we would we would definitely be talking
anything and again i think it i think
things can be off for sure and some
people think they're way off more than
others but
overall though i i just don't
i don't see that happening in the near
future at all
personally
so i have money in
in the banking system uh actually most
of our money is or in investments and so
yeah it's something that um that we're
doing so that's how we give a lot of
this advice as well is things that we're
doing but you could look linda um
how much did you say is in the bank
right now
that's it well it's a little over a
hundred thousand okay
yeah and and this may i don't know i'm
just thinking of a way to diversify i
think ken saying to me with a investment
professional is like is a great um step
but it could be you know if you
i don't know i don't know if i'm full
with it i was going to say you know buy
you know a little bit of real estate
like a condo or something and having
money and oh lord i just got rid of them
terrible
i was cautious you would say it i should
have said it and i want you to know as
soon as she said that i rolled my eyes i
i don't know why rachel told you that no
you know what listen a smartvestor pro
is going to give you honestly some
really great advice there are other
investment opportunities for you where
you are protected from the federal
government and again they can help you
on that so you've got some options smart
uh smart investors smart yeah hang on
the line we're gonna make sure that we
get you right to the spot on our website
smart vester pro
is the section on the website but our
team uh is gonna get you right there and
i want you to interview several people
ask all the questions linda that you
want to ask because you need to feel
comfortable there's even investments to
to go into linda that even have like a
moral scape that it's like okay if you
are a evangelical believer here's funds
around that like you could even look
specifically into different things for
sure um
and by the way to come back to what i
was saying the reason people use
offshore accounts is to protect their
money from their government so foreign
countries if you feel it's just it
sounds like a movie it sounds like a
movie there was a man you just put your
money in another country's bank it was a
movie with cameron diaz and he had like
all of his money i think it got legally
in his office no i was not suggesting
illegal that the money itself would be
illegally gotten but the that is a
viable thing to protect yourself from
your government yeah there's people
doing maybe we should be doing it all
right are you doing it ken no because
i'm okay i'm not worried about it it's
going to be all right you know i think
you know it's going to be okay linda i
promise this is show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
the ramsay show continues from our
ramsey solutions worldwide headquarters
in nashville
i'm ken coleman rachel cruz joins me and
we're thrilled that you've joined us
triple eight eight two five five two two
five joshua is up in lexington kentucky
joshua how can we help
hi ken hi rachel thank you for taking my
call you bet um i'll go ahead and get
straight to it uh i just
so i've been working since 2000
of 2012
i have a bachelor's in political science
and masters
in
in american government and executive
leadership i just feel like i'm having a
difficult time
digging myself out of uh low-income jobs
um and getting to my sweet spot job
which is why um
i feel like i'm very passionate about
politics working in and around politics
i worked for the
last kentucky governor's
office
until he lost his reelection
um and i've been applying for different
like uh christian lobbyist groups
and i've gotten interviews i've
networked with people
but i just can't seem to break back in
sure so what were you making when you
worked for the governor of kentucky
that was again an another low income
sure it was about 34
a year how old are you and
i am 29. okay are you married
yes kids have kids okay
so yes i got one on the way in december
all right congrats good so when i asked
you what that sweet spot or dream job
was you just said i love politics i'm
just curious what's at the top of the
ladder it's really important even though
it may feel very out of reach right now
i don't want to focus on that i just
want to know
what would be
that ultimate gig and then quickly tell
me what's two or three levels up the
ladder
that you feel like i've identified ken
and if i got in this position i'd be
thrilled professionally and financially
would be much better off give me those
two answers
yes so my ultimate goal is to one day
run for kentucky governor gotcha all
right and then what's two or three
levels up the ladder obviously i think
the role with a a christian lobbyist uh
organization or a political organization
a pac or something like that
uh give me another example of something
a couple levels up that you've
identified where you are making maybe 50
60 uh thousand dollars or more
right and
and that would i feel like be on on the
governor's staff probably not the
president's day governor staff here in
kentucky
but
maybe a future governor
on his staff to where i would be
involved traveling around sure the state
getting to know people all right so
working here's the advice i'm going to
give you and i want you to understand
that it comes from experience
i was 22 years of age when i started
working for the governor of virginia and
um it was a i think it was a 32 000 a
year job and it was starting out and
then i work through different campaigns
but here's what i know from that world
whether it's virginia or kentucky it's
an extremely small world
you know that
i mean you know somebody that knows just
about anybody in kentucky politics and i
would also say that if you want to make
the move to washington and i don't know
if that's an option for you you know
plenty of people that can get you in
there and i think that you're a little
bit discouraged i understand
but what you've got to do is get
determined instead of staying
discouraged and you've got to leverage
your relationships you know a lot of
people you work for the governor of
kentucky so you've got a good political
resume and you've got great
relationships this is you just getting
very serious about making connections
say all right i want to work for and i
could throw up you know i'll just throw
out a
a it's a non-political party affiliation
but america's for prosperity huge
organization the koch brothers started
it very conservative you may be on the
liberal side doesn't matter they've got
you know george soros has got an
organization point is you start going
okay here's one organization here's uh
you know some offices in dc maybe some
uh think tanks uh maybe actually working
for a cabinet secretary in one of the
federal agencies and you've got state
agencies in kentucky my point is you
know all this but you've got to put all
this out almost on it's almost like a
mental piece of paper and then get
serious about who do i know over here
over here over here over here and it's
all about relationships you've got
enough of a resume
i wish i had some like silver bullet but
politics more than any other industry
is about who you know and who will vouch
for you and give you a gig i'm just i i
wish i had a better piece of tactical
advice
but you've already been in
so you can get back in it would be a
much more difficult proposition rachel
if he had never been in politics that's
a harder deal to get into so for sure
you just got to stay with it joshua but
you can do it hang on the line i'm gonna
i'm gonna give you a head start i want
to give you my book the proximity
principle
and
this is a book that's all about people
and places and it's very tactical and i
think it will help encourage you and
give you some very tactical things to do
day in and day out to get in that
business thank you for the call samantha
is up next in philadelphia pennsylvania
i would say the city of brotherly love
just to irritate right now i was waiting
i was waiting
you need to know these things somebody's
got to teach you culture rachel uh
samantha you're on the ramsay show how
can we help
hi ken hi rachel thanks for taking my
call thank you samantha george
washington code all in philadelphia was
he did he do anything can give us give
us the george washington was definitely
in philadelphia no for all the stuff he
was for all the things right there throw
that out there okay i'm sorry samantha
i'm here for your question
no no worries so i'm trying to figure
out
um
how much house i should buy okay um
i want to sell my house
i think i can get
around 500.
how much do you owe on it
nothing it's paid off oh wow that's
great
so why do you want to sell this house
i'm sorry why do you want to sell this
house that's paid off
i'm just i've been here 15 years
i
i know i heard you guys talking about
hetv but i want it was my starter house
and i want something a little bit better
i'm i'm in my 40s so i want something
that
you know that i can keep for another 15
years good for you yeah there's no
there's just stepping up you're stepping
up yeah we were just curious of what
your motivation is yeah
yeah yeah
um but but that is my question is
should i be going for that i mean i
could get something that's 500 and it
would probably have
what i'm looking for i got a sneaky
suspicion samantha you know exactly what
you're looking for and you know the
price range is that right or am i wrong
that's right but i will tell us the
number trying to give myself permission
well rachel's going to walk you through
it hit rachel with the number what's the
house how much is going to cost the one
that you would like
500.
wait 500
though you just said yeah so you're just
flopping you're you're just taking from
your house to the other one
yeah but it was fun that's fine with the
update
do what
it's one with the update
yeah it's great yeah but the point is
you're not we i thought you were going
to throw 800 000 out and then i was
going to let rachel walk you through how
we would walk through that decision but
it sounds like you're just
you're gonna sell one house that's worth
500 and buy another one for 500 are we
hearing you right
yeah well my thought was i was trying to
be responsible so it's just me
unfortunately but it's just me um so i
didn't know if i should just you know
suck it up and get like three months do
it samantha stop
no
go get the house you want go get the
house you want and you're paying cat
you're basically paying cash for it's
amazing you've worked hard
it's the thing you want yes go get it go
enjoy yes is that what you wanted to
hear samantha spend some yeah time there
watched you beat spaghetti just like
enjoy your life enjoy your life
i mean the sage advice today is it's
unbelievable thank you for
sharing that samantha rachel said you
could go eat spaghetti in your new house
what else do you need to hear i was
thinking do you feel good now you should
go do it samantha okay so man
the next 15 years you've been dreaming
about this you're so in financial
position to do it this is not silly
and even if you're gonna take a small
mortgage out on another house i wasn't
gonna be like super mad about it right
that's what i thought i was asking so
yeah yes yes fantastic enjoy enjoy it
thank you for the call samantha you're
amazing
in that segment we mentioned the city of
brotherly love george washington and
spaghetti for those of you that are
keeping score you're welcome
this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm ken
coleman i'm joined in our studio today
by my co-host and colleague rachel cruz
thrilled to have you with us triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's the toll-free number to jump in
blinds.com 100 satisfaction guarantee
means even if you mismeasure or pick the
wrong color now i would be the guy who
mismeasures the good news is
they'll remake your blinds for free when
your husband's a dope like i am you get
free samples free shipping and with the
new promos they run every month you'll
save even more use the promo code ramsay
to get the best deal and today's
question comes from cassandra in the
united kingdom
oh there we go
the uk ken please do it in an action i
know i wish i could yeah i totally would
have
do you like a spot
okay my husband and i are currently
overseas in the uk as a military spouse
i've found it extremely difficult to
find a side hustle
i have 14 800 in student loans we do not
own a home and have no other consumer
debt i would like to find a side hustle
here in england but it's difficult since
we are american and i'm not sure what to
do to increase cash flow any advice yeah
cassandra i want you to start with the
base you know
this is a this is a safe place to start
because
you may not know a ton of people on the
base but your husband does and
you've got a group of
military men and women
many in the same situation that maybe
you're in you might be surprised how
many other military spouses have found
side hustles
all around the world as they've traveled
you know they're it's not their first
time yeah and and so i would start with
relationships on base hey i'm looking to
make a little bit of extra money uh and
talk to anybody and everybody you know
you might be surprised how an
opportunity will come out of those
relationships experience matters
and there's so many you know i've talked
to many military spouses
on this very question they'll call in on
the ken coleman show and and it's almost
every time when they
they they dive into that base of women
who are in the same situation or maybe
more experience of traveling
opportunities come your way and then the
good old-fashioned just get out there
and see who wants help well that ends i
mean obviously there's a time difference
but i
uh i mean look online like other things
you can do from like
whether it's two i don't know what it
would be but like an online job that you
can do where the hours aren't crazy
she's in the uk you know so the point is
she's she's on site so she can go and
say hey where do they need help and and
so just good old-fashioned show up and
apply
for opportunities so thank you for the
question okay so how many times have you
found yourself saying one day
one day i'll do this one day i'll buy a
house one day i'll be happy with my
career one day i won't be battling
anxiety
well
whatever your one day is you can
actually start right now and that's one
reason we created the smart conference
so the smart conference it's a one day
event where we tackle all the areas of
your life and you guys a lot of us could
just use a nice little boost right now
so you're gonna hear from the nation's
top leading experts on money career
mental health relationships marriage and
leadership
so we are going to dallas texas on
saturday october 22nd events are or the
event passes are selling fast vip and
platinum are already sold out but you
can still get general access passes for
39 dollars so it'll be myself ken
coleman next to me dr john deloney
george campbell christina ellis
dave ramsey craig and amy groschel from
life church
and of course we have some some
surprises throughout the day which is
always fun so this is a really fun event
you guys if you have not gotten your
tickets and you're in the dallas area or
want to travel to the dallas area for it
it's an all-day event and it's really
fun some great content so you can visit
ramseysolutions.com
events to get your passes today what's
your one day give me your give me one
one day for you oh that's a good
question uh
oh man don't come on you got up several
one days like one day you want to have
lunch with taylor swift i went
t-swift i don't even know if that's true
i just made that up what a gal yeah um
one day
i would i and it's it's a kid thing but
like once the kids are gone i just want
to travel
i want to one day i'll just like go to
europe i'll be a full-time traveler not
full-time but i want to enjoy time away
traveling and seeing stuff but i just
feel like you know it's hard right now
of course you're in the middle i can't
like three little i mean i guess i could
leave for two weeks but i'm probably not
going to leave them with papa dave
that's what i would do i'm leaving with
them tonight actually so fantastic
thanks papades there it is you gotta
love that what's your one day
well i have several first one that comes
to mind is a uh is a hole in
i i want i want to achieve uh getting up
on a tee box of a part three and hitting
it in hole in one just feels just one
day just watching it just yeah it's
gonna be pretty amazing yeah that's a
good one day there you go just like both
of ours are achievable ken
i believe in us enough i do too i got to
play a lot more golf and increase those
chances so that that's probably yeah
it's grown and out of the house all
right there it is folks uh the one days
uh right there great examples let's go
to the phones jose is joining us in el
paso texas jose how can we help
yesterday
good afternoon sorry if i uh get my
words mixed up i'm a little nervous but
you're doing you're great jose you're
doing great
thank you um recently we my wife and i
had been around a lot of deaf we lost
both my in-laws which is six months
apart from each other oh my gosh
two years ago i lost my my uncle uh last
week i lost my other uncle about three
weeks ago my wife's last uh her best
friend's uh son from a 15 year old son
from cancer so um it opened up her eyes
a little bit and we've been looking into
getting the life insurance and uh
because it's just me my wife and my my
18 year old daughter
um you know we don't want us to struggle
in case anything were to happen to any
of us so yeah um we had somebody come
over to talk to us and i know mr ramsey
says not to get a whole life because
there's a time share of insurance uh
life insurance so we're i was looking at
term because that's what i learned from
listening to the show um but one thing
she brought up was was universal and
i've never heard of universal so
i wanted to get you guys feedback on
that i mean it's basically in the same i
the same sector of whole life i mean
it's it's just the idea you'll have
investment yeah so no it's
it it kind of coats itself a little bit
better than than whole life the way it
presents itself but it is that so no i
we do not recommend
uh universal term life is exactly the
route you need to go because it's still
going to be less expensive than
universal
um
and uh
and again you're keeping your
investments and your insurance separate
which is what term life does there's
nothing else attached to it where a lot
of these other options are more
expensive and they have an attachment of
some type of investment with it so um
yeah term life is where and i would just
honestly jose go to xander.com and they
have such a great
easy
interface if you've if you've gone to it
before you just like really put in some
information and go through a few steps
and then they bring out all of these
companies that have it's not just one
specific company they go and shop all
these companies to really figure out the
best needs for your family so um that's
where i that's where my husband and i
have got ours i mean they just make it
so easy
and i'm really proud of you guys for
doing this i mean seriously
life insurance is one of the things that
is
key so so important to do for your
family that a lot of people just skip
that step so i'm really proud of you and
your wife for doing it and even if she's
a stay-at-home mom
um i would still get life insurance on
her as well uh anyone that's dependent
upon your income okay good good good
jose have you ever been through this
i'm sorry i'm sorry have you ever been
through this process before is this
going to be your first time kind of well
this is this is all completely new to us
obviously um she she's the girl that was
talking to us about it she broke it down
but
i just uh i don't want to make the wrong
move and that's why i said no you know
what let me call it she's she's shopping
around for us because she works for a
company that that has that
she even sells like obamacare and all
sorts of insurance and so so yeah she's
shopping around for us but uh well i
just wanted to make sure we didn't get
locked into something that that we need
that is not beneficial and jose you
don't even need an insurance agent like
that i mean like no you do not you can
do it yourself you could but i mean dave
and jeff zander have known each other
for three decades i know jeff personally
rachel knows jeff it's a wonderful
company we endorse them because they're
shopping for you
for the best policies and they're only
going to recommend terms so you're not
going to have to learn about some new
type of insurance as rachel said i would
get with them today i mean before you go
to bed get online it's a i think it's
less than a couple of minutes you can
get a free quote they're very good
people tell them you talked to rachel
and i on the show today and we said take
really good care of you yeah ask all the
questions you want to ask and it's a
simple process i got to give you one
little tip though that you're not going
to get many times when you ask about
this i've recently got the best rate
possible let me tell you something no
cheeseburgers like eat super lean for 30
days before the life insurance matters
no smoking no alcohol and i'm telling
you you get that right preferred rate
when you got the low cholesterol there
it is folks thanks jose for calling in
thank you jose this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back america you're listening to
the ramsay show i'm ken coleman i'm
joined by my colleague rachel cruz
thrilled that you are with us our
scripture of the day comes from proverbs
18
24. there are friends who destroy each
other but a real friend sticks closer
than a brother our quote today ray
goforth
there are two types of people who will
tell you that you cannot make a
difference in this world those who are
afraid to try and those who are afraid
you will succeed
yeah that's good i find that a lot with
family sometimes right not my personal
family but i hear from callers you know
it's like family tries to hold people
back they're afraid
that if you actually succeed they're
gonna go a long way away or leave them
in the dust let's go to william who
joins us in wichita kansas william how
can we help
uh hello can you hear me yes sir loud
and clear what's up okay
you cut out there for a second all right
um basically my question is since me and
my wife can't get a loan from a bank for
a house
um should we have my dad get the loan
and get the house in his name and then
pay him back for it
have you shopped around
dylan have you guys tried like two three
four other places from mortgage brokers
to credit unions other banks
um
basically
since we can't we can't get a loan
that's government secured because we
haven't had too stable income which
apparently non-negotiable
now there may be in-house loan options
but those will be
adjustable rate and higher interest rate
yeah my dad can get for himself
yes okay you're kind of cutting out a
little bit dylan um okay so where are
you guys at financially what what kind
of debt do you have
uh we're great debt besides credit card
month to month which gets paid off at
the end of every month
okay
score is good cash is good how much how
much do you have saved two years
uh how much do we have saved um
about
about 50 000 about 50 is that part of
your emergency fund and down payment
um yeah that's that's every that's all
liquid cash we have it okay
okay perfect
um
are you still there
yeah okay okay yeah so um i do not i i
mean it's kind of in a sense a
co-signing situation i mean he's taking
the loan out but it's on your behalf
and honestly dylan we just don't
recommend doing it with family even
though it sounds probably fine and it's
not a big deal
i
i would recommend you and your wife
be stable on a job for
two years and then you guys go get the
loan yourself um how old are you guys
um i'm 20 and the wife's 22. oh yeah
okay what has to be true for you all to
then what what financial stability you
mentioned this earlier cutting out but
there's some things that you didn't have
in place and so you couldn't get the
loan so what has to be true for you to
be able to qualify
that has to be true is two years of
stable income okay in our chosen career
paths okay so
here's the deal um you're 20 and 22
the house a house that you want to buy
william is going to be there
okay
so you got to lay out this groundwork
don't get in the situation with your dad
it could be a situation that could go
ugly create unnecessary tension and
again you're so young you guys can rent
and uh get stable get in your
professions
and uh just just you're not going to
write nothing right there's no william
too i'm sorry i called you dylan earlier
sorry william
uh and i would say this too i would i
would give this advice even if you were
38. even at 38. i still wouldn't i
wouldn't have my dad take out a loan and
that i mean it's just it just changes
relationship and i think it's not a
great habit to be in even you know
especially since you guys are young i'm
like you have the time that's the great
part you have more positive on your side
for that you guys are okay
um home ownership will be in your future
and i would just make it independent of
you guys too because dylan that's going
to be a little bit i think of
um
i think of a dignity for you as well
that you and your wife you are your own
unit you know you are
you have left
you have left mom and dad and you guys
got to figure it out on your own and
there's something about that
um that i think is gonna be really good
for you and your wife and it's and i
think too i'm like any goal that you
have
and for some people it's getting out of
debt for some people it's getting a
house but when you do it as a married
couple
and you do what what's hard and right
this would be hard for y'all we're
giving you more of a hard road i think a
healthier road long term
uh but it's a hard road but when you
walk a hard road with your spouse and do
the quote unquote
impossible or the hard thing
there's something that happens in your
marriage dylan and a little bit of it
can kind of feel like a cop out of like
well dad can figure it out and take care
of it for us and we can you know we can
get what we want right now there's a
little bit of the struggle
that i think is so good and like i mean
i remember when winston and i we saved
up and we built a house we had saved for
years and years and years and years and
moved in november of 19 and i remember
remember that leading up as we're having
to make those withdrawals during that
build i mean it was like cut we were
cutting stuff out of the budget and we
were every commission thing i could do i
was like i'm doing i mean it was just
this moment of like we're going to do it
and when we finish that project i mean
him and i just remember walking through
the doors of that house and we were like
we did like we mean so much more there
is something about that strengthens your
marriage dylan that i don't think you
could get otherwise so all that to say i
think there's a lot of a lot more pros
by you guys just working hard for two
years on a job that you love buying a
house on your own you guys can do it
you're smart you're doing great you're
young it's perfect
and there's a lot of downside that could
happen uh not that it always would
happen with your dad but if it does go
south it's not good yeah it's not fun i
agree
now we go to dylan poor william
dylan about 17 times but you were on
such a role i didn't really feel the
need to curse our board the board that
we look at for the callers i messed up
the color it's all right i was looking
at the orange now we're going to dylan
so don't call him william all right
that's all the audience wants and me
quite frankly dylan you're on the ramsey
show
uh hey can y'all hear me okay william
how confused how confused were you on
the last call she kept talking to you
and you're like oh she can't hear me
uh it's okay no it's actually that's
okay because i'm 22 and my wife's 22 and
we just got married in april oh
congratulations oh the marriage is fine
there you go you and william all right
y'all could be friends yeah all right so
we got about two minutes how can we help
okay so basically i have a car loan
that's eight thousand dollars
and i have student debt that's sixty
five hundred dollars
and i've got eleven thousand four
hundred dollars in savings
um
so if i paid off my car loan first which
is the higher which is why i'm calling
y'all because it's the higher one
um but it would save me 416
a month
if i paid it off first and then attacked
the student loan
i don't know with them being so close
i'm not sure if i should just go ahead
and pay the car out first even though
it's the higher one
uh i mean
honestly yeah dylan i would i would go
ahead and knock out the student loan
debts and then work to
um to pay off the car i mean you're not
going to be that far off and so
i don't know that i i understand what
you're saying about the interest and all
of that but i would just go ahead and
just pay off the student loan there's
something that feels good about just
saying
okay i'm done i'm done with that student
loan it's it's done
and then you guys have just like what
three thousand more to go tackle
for the car loan and you guys how much
do you make a year
uh
net like seventy five thousand okay oh
yeah okay well then
yeah
okay so yeah i mean five thousand left
you could sell a couple things around
the house get some money together yeah i
would get 11 000 did i hear you say 11
000 in savings
yeah yeah okay
so you know what we teach there take
that down to 1 000 right and yeah and
use all of that 10 on this process but i
think you can knock this out really
quick yeah but yeah go go go through the
the debt snowball that's what it works
every time
all right awesome yep appreciate the
call thanks dylan yeah there you go i'm
very excited that you got his name right
that's uh that's that's always good um
in all seriousness why why this why the
snowball why the momentum like
you know like why do we tell people
every time it actually works i know
you've taught this many times you've had
this call many times this is not a math
i mean debt to a point is not a math
issue it's more of a behavior issue and
so getting out of it there's something
about those quick wins
that just feel like gosh it just it just
feels great and so so he's asking okay
if i'm gonna have 10 grand can i throw
it at the eight
have two left and then knock out the
student loans so yeah i mean like dylan
you could do that because i understand
what you're saying
but then there's something about having
the momentum of having the student loan
gone the the lowest throwing any extra
that you had at the car and then
attacking that car so there's just it's
a it's a feeling of that behavior change
happening that helps people win
rachel cruz always fun to be with you
thanks for hanging out today i want to
thank james and the team behind the
booth for what they do
mostly we want to thank you america we
do the show for you thank you so much
for listening in today this is the
ramsay show
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
you